するんです 目には音は入らない
目には何も入らない 耳に音は入らない
体で何も感じない 心も回転しない
究極的な幸福を感じてるんだと
それでそれをさらに続けちゃうんです
それはもう一時間 二時間じゃなくて
どんどん時間伸びて ここは一週間もその状態でいることできるんだと
一週間も続く それでお釈迦様も負けました
確かにお釈迦様はこういうことできれば
一部日間でもできれば
それは究極的な幸福だと私も認めますよ
ですからもう負けましたと
お釈迦様こそ究極的な贅沢をなさってないんだと
我々は ということの結果になったんです
ですから 仏教はこういう苦しみの道ということではないんです
だからこの集中しちゃうと本当に素晴らしく喜びが生まれてきます
それは量がないんです
いくらでも生まれる 苦しみには量があるんで
それ以上人間に苦しみないってことはある
それ以上苦しみ死んじゃうんです
でも幸福にはそれないんです
量が いくらでも成長することはできます
それは心の問題だから
幸福がないかっていうことは
あの猿の例え まあこれ私個人の例えなんですけど
皆様に一つ宿題で出します
皆様ヘビが嫌いでしょう
見るにも嫌でしょうね
毛が立っちゃうし ヘビも結構可愛いんです
だからそれを頭に入れておいて
こいつら何が可愛いんですか？気持ち悪いのにという気持ちで見てください
よくよく見るとすごく可愛く見え始めるんです
ですから 私は猿の実験しましたから
皆さんもヘビの実験でもしてみたらどうですかね
いわゆるそういう風にやっぱり研究しないと仏教も理解できないんですよ
ヘビを見ていくと どんどんどんどんどんどん可愛く可愛く見えてくるんです
ですから 喜びっていうものは心の状態で
心の動き 状態によって変わるもので
心はだから論理的には心を落ち着いたら喜びが生まれる
ヘビでも落ち着いてみると
何の醜いものも何もないと分かりますし
綺麗し体が ビニール製みたいですからね
全然ホコリは何もないんです
ここでピカピカと光っているし
それで模様の綺麗なこと
そこで随分落ち着いてるでしょ
ヘビっていうのは どうかじーっとしているんですね
だからイラつくような猿と違って
猿っていうのは本当に落ち着いてないんだから
見てるとどんどん もうこの野郎と言いたくなっちゃいますけど
このあっちこっちあっちこっち
ああだこうだ もう で 猿の場合はこのメンリルという芸術作品みたいな猿がいるんです
英語ではメンリルと言うんですね
あの顔の方が青い 赤い
いろいろ線があって これオスのオスですけどね
座ってると堂々たる姿で
なんか顔の綺麗なこと
本当になんか誰かこの画家が描いたような感じなんですね
顔の美しさというのは
日本動物園に今すごい珍しい種類の猿なんですけど
まあとにかく落ち着いた方が幸福が生まれて
ですから瞑想からも幸福
喜悦感が生まれてくる
そこはこれぐらい楽しいってことじゃなくて
どんどんどんどん成長しちゃうんですね
だからこのサマーディ瞑想に興っちゃう人々が
もうこれこそ真理は悟っただ
まあだこうだとバカでかことを言うのは
この本物の人だったらね
で もうそれはこの瞑想しちゃうとどんどん湧いてくる喜びがあるんですね
それは確実なもので ただごまかしでもないんです
喜んでいるなど 自分を騙してるわけじゃないんです
だって喜びの場合 騙すことはできませんからね
例えば美味しいか美味しくないというのは
本当に正直に心知ってるでしょ？ご飯なんか食べてる時は
まあちょっと建前で あ
これはすごい美味しいよと言ったっても
やっぱり感覚的には美味しいかないかっていうのはもうすでに決まってるもんなんですね
音楽の場合も 耳に入った瞬間で気持ちいいかないかもう決まってるんでしょうね
それでこの間 日曜日かな
ちょっとあるどこか行ったんだけど
遊びに行って ある一人の若い人があの何て言いますか
オープンテイタスみたいなところがあって
そこで演奏してるんですね
まあ月例会なんとかって
もう毎月やってるところで
で 一人のドイツ人が一生懸命歌ってるんですね
で 私はそこに入って まあ頑張ってはいるんだけど
まあそれなりに でもまあ
あまりそんなに聞いて喜ぶという感じがしないんだけどね
でも一旦座ったんだから
もうそんなこと聞いていられないと
立っちゃったら失礼だとね
せっかく一生懸命歌ってるんだからね
本当に必死で汗もう暑いしね
汗だくしながらもう一生懸命そこですごいいろいろ楽器機械使ったりしてね
まああまり人はもう二十人三十人もいなかったし
五 六 七 八人ぐらいでしたし
それでまあ一曲終わるまででもね
聞いてあげようと思っていたんだけど
私の連れの人がもうもうもうあまりにも帰ろうと言ったんだから
まあ僕も文句言いながら失礼でしょう
一曲終わるまででも待っていた方がいいんではないかなと言いながら
僕も帰ってしまったんだけどね
だからその時でも 正直なところは耳に音を触れた瞬間で
まあピーティが生まれるかないかっていうのはもう決まってるもんだからね
もしその本人が私に話したならば
私は話すことできたならば
僕はものすごい褒めてあげますよ
素晴らしいと それはまあ普通の挨拶であって
別にあなたの歌が良くないよと言う必要ないし
何の意味もないし その人もできれば成長してほしいしね
人気あってね もう歌手になってくれれば
別にそれはその人の幸福だからね
ですからそこは別に嘘じゃないんですよ
まあそれなりに歌ってましたからね
ですから このピーティの場合は別にごまかしがないんです
だから瞑想していると
サマーディ瞑想でもしていると
本当に喜びが生まれてくる
どんどん広げていく そこであるところで
ああ これこそ究極やと思っちゃったら
それでその人ストップしますけどね
ですから なかなか抜けられないんですよ
真理の世界には その喜びにふけてそこで終わっちゃうんですね
だからこういう瞑想麻薬というか
このサマーディ瞑想して喜びを感じちゃう
ちゃうともう中毒で もう解脱の道にはもう絶対来ない
絶対来ないというのはもう来る子はないというか
もう麻薬中毒で瞑想中毒
もう気絶感中毒になっちゃうんですね
で ヴィパッサナーではそこでもやっぱりもうちゃんと気をつけて
もう中毒にならないようにしておきますけど
それならば解脱することは一番大事なポイントですけど
その過程では喜びはあるんです
で チャンダと言われます
もう時間は飛んじゃった
で チャンダっていうのはこの精進と似ているんです
で チャンダっていうのはもう欲という日本訳でしょうね
意欲 やる気ですね ですから
何か認識 この心の問題で認識しようと思ったら
このしたいという気持ちがあるならば
それをチャンダと言うんです
意志っていうのはまた何か似てるんだけど
あのー チェータナ 似てるんだけど
その場合はなんかポテンシャルエネルギー作っちゃいますけど
チャンダの場合はそういうエネルギーは作りません
単なるやる気 でもこれ育てられます
これも育てるんで お釈迦様はこの
このチャンダはすごく成長させちゃったんです
完成したんですね ですから尽力と言うんです
神通力の一つ 基本神通力作る場合は基本四つ必要なんですね
チャンダ チッタ ヴィリヤ
ヴィマンサと で チャンダはこれ意欲
これはこのやる気というエネルギーをどんどん成長する
活発的というか もうこれこの
この暗示やったりする人々も結構ありますね
なんかもう本当にあんたはこれ眠くなります
眠くなりますとものすごい気持ちが良くなります
なんとなくそのいろいろ服装やら言葉の話し方やら
そういういろんなことで
もうなんとなくなんか変な雰囲気ですけど
相手がまあ眠ってしまっちゃう
だから中途半端な気持ちで人に暗示かけてみようとして暗示かけてみてください
全然かかりません で そういうこと
まあそれとこれは関係ないんだけど
チャンダというのは意欲であって
やる気であって やる気はどんどん成長しちゃうと本当に何でもすごくする
ああやりま これもこれもなんだ
なんだかんだやってしまっちゃうというふうなエネルギーなんですね
そのエネルギーはすごく成長しちゃうと
自分の意思通りに物事を変化させることができます
だから 物事を変化させることに人間が神通力と言うんですね
で それからヴィリヤ これも尽力に入るんですよ
精進 で もう決めたものはとにかくやってしまう
そのああだこうだとかね
もう何もいろいろ文句言ったらああだこうではなくて
もうやり遂げる 精進ということで
その二つは尽力とも言ってるんですからね
育てられます ですから
このやる気というエネルギーも育てればよろしいなんですよ
意欲っていうのは 例えば私にいろいろあるでしょう
あれもやりたいと これもやりたいという気持ちだけあるんだけど
やらない それやる気のエネルギーはないんですね
ですから したいことがいろいろあって
それすぐすぐ実行するのは意欲のエネルギーはある人なんですね
その意欲のエネルギーは何で欲しいかというと
そうでないと全部ストレス溜まっちゃうんですね
夏はもう外国旅行もしたいし
やっぱり日本 まあそういう風になっちゃうと
やりたいこといっぱいあって一索しないでしょう
そうすると全部ストレスなんですね
結局気持ち悪くなっちゃって
暗くなっちゃって終わってしまっちゃうんですね
やる気がある人がやる気が出てくると
やりたいものは少なくなっちゃうんです
自然的に 何かこれじゃあやりますと
もうすぐそれやるんだから
もう時間も今もないんだから
心はそこに行っちゃいますから
ですからストレスはないんです
だからストレス解消のためには
このやる気っていうエネルギーが育てればすごくいいんです
ストレスいっぱい溜まっちゃうっていうのは
このやらなくちゃいけないことがあるんだと
でもかえってこれもやりたい
あれもやりたいんだとかあるとストレスなんですね
洗濯もしなくちゃ 掃除もしなくちゃ
買い物にも行かなくちゃ
でもどこかへ行って 何かお茶も飲みなくちゃ
そういうふうなことを考えちゃうと
もうストレスなんですね
そういうふうに男性の場合もストレス溜まる場合は同じこと
女性の場合も同じ働きで
仏教では別に性差別はないんだから
心理の世界は この物質的にはこの色の説明ではあっただけであって
ですから同じなんですね
そういうことで終わります
[拍手]